so ladies no big deal just making
history just making history here
casual casual pretty good
you know i was when i watched the movie
i got like emotional
actually when i saw the characters come
out and they look like
uncles and aunts and cousins of mine
right and then i
turned to my kids who are watching and
kind of like how groundbreaking this
is was a bit lost on them but it didn't
matter it's
in a way that's kind of what we want
isn't it kelly yeah yeah
no exactly i think about that a lot like
i know that
for our generation you know growing up
not having had that
it is such a big deal to us recognizing
uh
just the way that we're we're part of
this positive change
of yeah the goal is to have kids see so
uh so many representations of people
that look like them and speak like them
and act like them
that they don't even recognize you know
the importance of
how important it is to us who didn't
have that um
yeah it's cool that you said that it's
really cool
it's it's awesome and watching the
credits something that was
really remarkable is like 400 people
worked on this basically from home
you don't you don't think about that at
all when you're watching the movie what
were your home setups like
for doing voice work from your house
aquafina
uh wow um you know
i we it it's not the same as i'll say
a disney studio it's that your home will
never be the same
or equipped like a disney studio but you
know we we
we tried to make it work and and and i
think that um there was something
special that that you know i'll always
remember about this lockdown because i
was able to do this movie through it
uh my living room had a giant production
tent because
the sound wasn't doing well in my actual
studio which i like made a whole room
for
so i had to move downstairs into a
production tent and
um i loved it i put a carpet down i had
a warm light going i had a philips hue i
put settings on
and i'd said and i loved it in there i
wanted to keep it i wanted to live in it
i had to give it back
i'm still upset um
[Laughter]
yeah there were i mean there were
definitely a lot of challenges which is
uh
figuring out how how to do that from
home i think in the beginning
everyone was no one knew that the
pandemic was going to become what it has
become
um and so to initially have to figure
out
what recording would look like i'm just
really grateful that my boyfriend is a
genius and was able to
create a makeshift fort that i got you
rewarded the whole time
um but yeah it was uh wild times wild
times for sure
was also amazing about this film for you
guys it's like these characters get to
live on now you know we don't see the
end of them anymore like now we get to
see
them in all sorts of different products
it's been awesome there's a whole
several years for raya that we don't
know what happened do you
can you imagine moving on and actually
filling in those gaps in that story
kelly
yeah um yeah that would be really cool
i was just thinking as you were as you
were telling me that story
i on one of my last recording sessions i
think it was actually adr aquafina and
we had to like
go in and and um do like whatever lines
we had to do and
and i remember being like oh i'm kind of
sad that's over like that's i guess
that's the last
one i felt that too
yeah and then paul the sound engineer um
turned to me and he says don't be sad
princesses never leave
and it was like just the sweetest thing
that you'll be back and it just made me
like
i don't know it was uh it was a really
special moment so yeah i can definitely
uh hopefully there'll be many many more
iterations of these characters
yeah well this is a really special movie
and i know that in our house we'll be
revisiting
it a lot probably as soon as tomorrow so
thank you so much for this time and i
hope to see you guys in person sometime
soon
thank you
you